ثاني اكسيد التيتانيوم ملون غذائي يستخدم
غالبا في الحلوى والاطعمه المصنعه لاعطاء
ملمس ناعم ولجعل الطعام اكثر جاذبيه لكن
هذه الماده المضافه ليس لها اي فائده
غذائيه كما تقول مجموعه العمل البيئيه
المنظمه المناصره للمستهلكين التي تدفع
باتجاه التشريع حظر المواد الكيميائيه
الموجوده في الحلوى والاطعمه المصنعه في
ولايه كاليفورنيا يوجد ثاني اكسيد
التيتانيوم في وصفات بعض الحلوى الامريكيه
لكنه لا يظهر في اكياس الحلوى المباعه او
المستهلكه في اوروبا فقد حضرها الاتحاد
الاوروبي العام الماضي اعتمادا على تقييم
اجرته هيئه سلامه الاغذيه الاوروبيه والذي
وجد ان ثاني اكسيد التيتانيوم لا يعد ام
عند استخدامه كمضافات غذائيه ولا تستبعد
الهيئه احتمال ان يكون لهذه الماده
المضافه تاثيرات مسرطنه بينما تصر الشركات
الامريكيه المصنعه على انها تتبع دائما
القواعد التنظيميه المحليه وانها تعد
وجباتها الخفيفه باعلى مستويات الجوده
وتلتزم بمعايير السلامه الصارمه وتقول ان
الوصفات تختلف قليلا في جميع انحاء العالم
لاستيعاب امكانات التصنيع والتوافر المحلي
للمواد الخام او تفضيلات الذوق المختلفه
للناس رؤيه تعززها اداره الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه التي تقول انه يمكن استخدام
ثاني اكسيد التيتانيوم بامان لتلوين
الاطعمه طالما ان نسبته لا تتجاوز واحدا
في المئه وزن الطعم وما بين الداعين الى
حظر المواد الكيميائيه الموجوده في الحلوى
والاطعمه المصنعه وبين المؤكدين على عدم
ضررها هناك من الباحثين من يجادل بان
لوائح السلامه الحاليه للموافقه على
استخدام ثاني اكسيد التيتانيوم تستند الى
مراجعات اجريت منذ عقود ويحث هؤلاء
الباحثون الحكومات على ضروره اعاده
تقييمها